[Music]
my eyes water can you zoom into my eyes
you'll see tears in my eyes right now if
you reading zoom into like you
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
show we give our guests two simple
options tell the truth or suffer the
wrath of the last DAP and today I'm
joined by sway Lee and slim Jimmy
together their race rumored the
platinum-selling hip hop duo you know
from hits like no type blackbeetles and
many more but can they Powerglide their
way through the tightrope of truth and
pain we'll find out today fellas welcome
to the show thank you how are you guys
with spicy food I hate spicy I love all
types of food spicy food is like my last
choice oh oh this is the show for you
let me break down the rules for you in
front of you you can see three scorching
hot chicken wings that have all been
doused in various versions of the last
dab I have a handful of deeply personal
may be awkward sometimes uncomfortable
questions for you and when I ask you a
question you have a choice either answer
it honestly or eat a death wing the
choice is yours are you guys ready to
get started if I seen this wing on the
menu I would not order that well you
know it's the only thing on the menu
today and Jimmy we're gonna start with
you because you're the oldest I think
that it's only fair let's go which race
rumored song do you think would be
better if your brother sway Lee weren't
on it and why
oh come on man what does what were just
always be it's your life
eating the wing that's a good brother
right there that's a good partner in
ironing anything hot never anything the
sauce is hot it's real love oh yeah all
right not that bad though I like that
I'm not really too excited
ah yeah sweetly I know that you're an
animal lover real wildlife fan you have
a whole menagerie of animals at your
house including a spider monkey though
named little G but I imagine that being
a rap superstar it's hard to balance
that with the care that you need for
those animals what's one time that you
are not a good pet owner um once I
wasn't a good pet owner like I had left
my I walked out the door too fast I had
somewhere to go so I walked out the door
too fast and I left my door like a
little bit cracked and like my dogs they
were following me I wanted to come with
me it's not that I just like I thought I
closed it but I ain't even cracked so
when I came back my dog
last minute
it happens to us all Jimmy how you doing
you clean that whole glass of milk
I still burning I thought I was doing it
right Jimmy you guys have collaborated
with some of the biggest artists from
future to Travis Scott to Pharrell but
I'm curious can you give me a
collaboration that you guys backed away
from not because of scheduling or the
money not being right but just because
the project the album the artist just
couldn't be associated with it oh man
what's that dude thanks delicious hey
song Gangstalicious yeah sure like yeah
it's Whaley blackbeetles it's one of the
biggest songs of the decade it spawned
the mannequin challenge it even got a
cosign from Sir Paul McCartney himself
but I'm curious how well do you know the
Beatles I have three rapid-fire Beatles
trivia questions for you if you get all
three right you're in the clear but if
you miss one it's a one-way ticket to
Scoville City over here okay you ready
ready
The Beatles gave their first ever live
us television performance on which
program the Dick Van Dyke Show The Ed
Sullivan Show are The Tonight Show
Starring Johnny Carson this Tonight Show
Starring Johnny Carson Carson
I'm gonna give you a little lifeline I
can see let's go to trivia questions I
wanna show me the common area but you
must not see me I drink the whole glaze
the cover of The Beatles eleventh studio
album has no title printed on it but
instead pictures the band walking an
iconic crosswalk in London can you name
that album and he wrote Abbey Road Abbey
Road all right one more one more race
rumored that is a doused chicken wing
I've never seen a dad like that in my
life so a lot at stake
here what is question question right
we'll just drink one of the bottles
right do it
which song did Frank Sinatra say was the
best love song of the past 50 years she
loves you
eight days a week something or Hey Jude
hey Judy
the answer is something and that is
something right there if I've ever seen
it oh hey everybody get your poles out
man
Instagram it's time for it we dig our
own graves on this show or maybe that
could be the lasting [ __ ] out I'm like a
sport
this is wild
oh listen I have been doing this show
for years I've never seen a dab like
that in all my life oh never seen the
devil I did oh yeah I could see that
coming all right slim Jimmy we couldn't
let you out of here without a challenge
for yourself and I know well so my gums
burning that you love your brother but
how well do you know his guest versus
you're just eating a wing off rip I know
I know two versus let's do it if you can
do the lyrics to sway Lee's verse on
Nightcrawler you're in the clear but if
not then it's the death wing but you've
already taken it down I don't know let's
focus on when I come running
oh yeah at night my eyes water can you
zoom into my eyes you see tears in my
eyes right now if you really assuming
something I give to my lips burning way
but sway the questions don't get any
easier who's a rapper that you are a fan
of growing up you know somebody you
idolize then maybe you met them in
person or worked at them in person it
was a little bit of a letdown oh so like
if you don't have like oh you can't like
name-drop you got it you got a wings
right yeah the week yeah that's [ __ ]
up that's both oh yeah hey that's how
life goes rockin right I know I feel
Iike me from this from the side of the
stage
yeah I feel that one right there it's
just a lot on your plate on to the last
round so you guys broke on to the
internet with these viral dance videos
when you're going under crew called them
outta state boys yes what do you
remember about the put it in rotation
routine right now I can do that [ __ ]
alright I got one more for you guys
before because before you made it big
you were hustling taking odd jobs
whether it was working in a mattress
factory or in the restaurant business
what's one corporate secret about Olive
Garden that they wouldn't want the
people out there to know the Busboys
still the tips from the service
well there you have it here first out of
breadsticks frozen that's two
volunteered and look at you guys sway
lis slim Jimmy answering the hot
questions and eating the scorching hot
chicken wings for the culture race
memory woody got milk complex we love
you I got two weeks left - hey man I ate
all my wings man it was a Jedi what's up
big boy